à la fresh bonsoir bonsoir
commençons sur parce que les gens se
rappellent de la campagne électorale
alors comment vous expliquer ce
changement effectivement on dit on en
accueille moins mais on va s'en occuper
mieux là on dit finalement on pourrait
aller jusqu'à 60 000 mais c'est qu'on
change complètement les règles du jeu
donc à partir du moment où les règles du
jeu sont différentes et ben c'est un
autre c'est un autre analyse qui peut
être menée on fait en sorte que les gens
qui viendront s'établir de manière
permanente au Québec à travers un
programme d'immigration économique
parleront français donc ce sont des gens
qui viendront grossir les rangs de la
population qui parle français donc quand
on disait au discours inaugural du
Premier ministre que
l'immigration doit être une solution
pour la langue française vous avez la
traduction de ce que ça veut dire quand
on dit que c'est une solution
l'immigration pour la langue française à
partir du moment où il y a la nécessité
il une exigence de connaître le français
on change complètement la donne et il
faut voir que jusqu'à maintenant les
programmes d'immigrations économiques ça
donnait des points que de connaître le
français ça fonctionnait avec une grille
d'analyse il fallait cumuler des points
si on en avait suffisamment on pouvait
être sélectionné alors on en a plus de
crise de points je vous je vous montre
qu'on montre aux gens un tableau parce
que ça va un peu avec ce que vous dites
cette année l'an 2022 dans la catégorie
que le Québec contrôle la catégorie
économique totalement et avec quand même
déjà 88% des gens qui avaient une
connaissance soit moyenne ou plus
avancée du français votre objectif c'est
de rendre de passer de 88 à 96 %, mais
en termes de nombre de personnes c'est
quoi
2000 j'ai fait le calcul
2600 personnes de plus long on parle de
cet ordre là mais c'était déjà pas mal
francophone mais c'est parce que vous
vous avez les chiffres ici de 2022 mais
permettez-moi de vous partager les
chiffres de 2018 en 2018 on était à
72%. alors vous voyez que chaque année
on cumulé quand même un bassin de
personnes qui venaient s'établir de
manière permanente au Québec et qui ne
maîtrisait pas nécessairement le
français donc c'est ça qu'on veut
changer et quand on dit qu'il faut
améliorer la situation du français et
bah tous les leviers vont compter même
ceux qui nous offrent des gains
peut-être plus marginaux mais vous voyez
que si on remonte un petit peu plus loin
dans le temps et bien dans le fond la
situation était forte donc c'est
vraiment important pour nous d'agir de
en ce sens-là vous reconnaissez que par
rapport à aujourd'hui ce n'est pas non
plus une totale révolution parce qu'on
était déjà vous aviez vous étiez arrivés
à 88 % déjà parce que c'est pas mal ça
dépend des programmes que l'on regarde
prenez par exemple le programme
investisseur c'est un des trois
programmes là associés aux gens
d'affaires le programme investisseur le
l'inventaire qu'on avait là les gens qui
parlaient français dans cette
commentaires là il y en avait cinq pour
ça 5 donc là on vient dire ces personnes
dorénavant devront à 100% parler
français alors quand vous parlez de
changer de donne ça c'est un exemple
très parlant on vient changer la logique
de l'ensemble des programmes de Jean
d'affaires de l'ensemble des programmes
d'immigrations économiques et ceux qui
permettait pour les travailleurs
qualifiés donc de cumuler des points
maintenant ça va être différent les gens
devront rencontrer des exigences donc il
y aura plus de points qui seront
accumulés on va leur dire là il faudra
parler français à un certain niveau soit
à l'oral ou à l'oral et à l'écrit et si
les exigences ne sont pas rencontrés
pourront pas être sélectionnés et le
niveau de du français va dépendre du
type d'emploi par exemple exactement
donc pour des emplois hautement
qualifiés qui requiert des diplômes
universitaires collégiales techniques ou
encore secondaire professionnel là il y
aura un niveau d'exigence de français
oral niveau 7 ça ça veut dire niveau
intermédiaire avancé il y a niveau en
tout d'accord pour des gens avec des
compétences plus manuelles et ça c'est
une nouveauté là vraiment intéressante
pour les PME on va demander un niveau de
connaissances du français à l'oral de
niveau 5 ça c'est le début du segment
intermédiaire qu'au niveau de
connaissances intermédiaire du français
ça ça va être super intéressant pour les
PME parce que plusieurs embauche des
travailleurs étrangers temporaires
aimeraient pouvoir les garder mais si je
la ne parvenait pas à être sélectionné
ne parvenait pas accumuler suffisamment
point dans le système actuel pour
pouvoir être sélectionné comme
immigrants permanent maintenant ils vont
avoir une passerelle alors je pense une
excellente nouvelle ça c'est important
ce que vous venez de dire je vais le je
veux le je veux le réexpliquer je vais
vous reposer une question quelqu'un qui
est déjà au Québec qui travaille qui est
arrivé ici invité par une entreprise par
exemple qui ne parle pas français et qui
a pris le français parce que il a
travaillé au Québec depuis quoi un an 8
mois dans des régions notamment vous
dites qu'il y aura une voie rapide pour
que cette personne là ne soit pas obligé
de alors qu'elle s'est intégrée parce
qu'il y a eu plein de cas documentés de
gens qui avaient des emplois qui et qui
arrivaient pas à rester effectivement
donc on voudra prioriser déjà des gens
établis au Québec donc le cas que vous
citez en région avec déjà un emploi ça
ça va être un profil d'une personne qui
va être priorisé si elle répond à nos
exigences en matière de langue française
même chose pour des étudiants on a un
programme qui est le PEC diplômé et pour
lequel franchement un œil très
intéressant parce que c'est l'exemple de
l'immigration idéale je vous dirais donc
ces gens-là vont être priorisés parce
que aussi ils ne viennent pas solliciter
davantage notre capacité d'accueil vous
savez qu'au niveau de l'habitation par
exemple c'est vraiment très très serré
même en région j'ai fait une tournée de
15 régions au cours des dernières
semaines partout on m'a parlé du manque
de logement donc quand on prend des gens
qui sont déjà établis ici ça veut dire
qu'ils ont déjà un logement ça veut dire
qu'ils sont déjà en intégration et ça on
favorise ça deux courtes la plus
rapidement est-ce que une entreprise qui
a besoin d'un ingénieur très spécialisé
l'entreprise d'aérospatiale par exemple
qui a besoin de quelqu'un qui est au
Japon qui est en Corée pour venir une
année ici est-ce que s'il ne parle pas
français du tout zéro là donc il ne peut
plus venir on pourra plus avoir cette
main d'oeuvre spécialisée mais de ne pas
vous venez de dire Sylvie pour une année
donc c'est pas de l'immigration
permanente il va prendre un permis de
travail temporaire donc ce sont pas les
mêmes règles que celles dont on vous
parle pour l'annonce d'aujourd'hui s'il
vient de manière permanente on a un
volet dans le programme des travailleurs
qualifiés qui s'appelle talents
d'exception donc quelqu'un qui vraiment
se démarque mais vraiment le se démarque
puis une renommée dans son secteur il a
une expertise très prisée par le Québec
qui est stratégique pour nous la
personne va pouvoir être repêché même
sans connaître le français donc ça c'est
un volet qu'on a intégré dans notre
programme de travailleur qualifié mais
pour vous dire que ça va être réduit le
nombre de personnes qui vont pouvoir se
qualifier là de s'improvise pas qui veut
talent d'exception on vous a beaucoup
reproché aujourd'hui l'opposition en
fait de ne pas parler justement de
l'éléphant dans la pièce Les temporaires
je vous montre un graphique vraiment ça
explose et il y en avait bon il y a une
baisse pendant la pandémie là mais
regardez 35000 en 2017 ça c'est sur une
base annuelle donc 86000 de plus
au Québec en 2022 au total ils sont plus
de 300 000 au Québec étudiant
travailleur saisonnier travailleur
temporaire alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec tous ces gens là est-ce que la
plupart on souhaite qu'il reste ici et
si c'est le cas donc c'est pour ça que
vous augmentez les seuils comment on
fait comment est l'exigence du français
n'est pas là pour ces gens-là mais d'une
part ce serait une fuite en avant que de
dire ok on va changer les règles pour
les temporaires sans changer les règles
pour l'immigration permanentes ceux qui
viennent ici pour le reste de leur vie
ben on veut qu'il cadre avec nos
conditions puis c'est ça sur quoi on a
travaillé d'établir des nouvelles règles
pour l'immigrations permanentes
maintenant dans un deuxième temps on va
regarder ce qui peut être fait en lien
avec l'immigration temporaire il faut
voir que l'immigration temporaire il y a
plusieurs profils c'est pas un code
figure il y en a comme vous dites qui
sont des étudiants étrangers il y en a
qui viennent à travers un programme qui
a une gestion partagée avec le Québec et
le fédéral il y en a qui viennent avec
un programme qui n'est que fédéral pour
lequel le Québec n'a pas de mot à dire
et c'est ça pourquoi d'ailleurs on
demande leur rapatrier nos pouvoirs du
fédéral pour pouvoir voir pour pouvoir
avoir un contrôle sur l'ensemble de
notre immigration mais pour nous ça
allait de soi que fallait commencer par
définir des règles qui nous conviennent
pleinement qui aident à améliorer la
situation du français en lien avec
l'immigration permanente d'abord et
avant tout ça aurait été une fuite en
avant que de procéder à l'inverse il
serait logique mais
ultime à quand et quels sont les
objectifs pour faire face parce que
les gens disent qu'ils ne se font pas
servir en français à Montréal ou
ailleurs c'est souvent des des gens qui
font partie du groupe parapluie
immigration temporaire reçoit des
étudiants soit des gens qui ont alors
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour mieux
franciser ces gens-là d'une part il faut
voir que c'est important de le dire le
près de 60% des temporaires parlent
français donc c'est pas si on est comme
si on était à la case départ nous au
ministère de l'Immigration on a des
mesures de francisation des cours de
français à Sion qui sont donnés je vais
d'ailleurs annoncer là dans quelques
jours francisation Québec qui va être la
porte d'entrée officielle pour toutes
les mesures de francisation offerte par
le gouvernement en collaboration avec
des partenaires donc tous les
temporaires ont accès au cours de
francisation il faut voir que sous les
libéraux cet accès là était pas permis
alors je suis pas mal surprise
d'entendre mon collègue libéral dire que
ce serait bien important de franciser
les temporaires parce que quand c'était
eux qui étaient au ce n'était pas
possible pour les temporaires d'accéder
aux mesures de francisation or avec
l'arrivée du gouvernement actuel on a
rendu cet accès possible et au cours des
derniers mois de la dernière année il y
a eu un doublement du nombre de
travailleurs étrangers temporaires qui
ont pris des cours de francisation c'est
donc il y a vraiment un momentum et sur
lequel on veut miser pour croître encore
plus la connaissance du français donc
pour conclure Madame Fréchette quand on
dit quand Monsieur le goût disait que
c'est du suicide etc pourtant on
soulevait la question on dit oui mais
vous avez juste à accueillir plus
d'émigrations francophones on se dit
ouais mais c'est pas possible là vous
nous dites que c'est possible
d'accueillir plus d'immigrations
francophones l'immigration va changer de
nature de de coin à géographique mais
vous dites
on est allé regarder chacun des leviers
dont on dispose pour l'immigration que
l'on contrôle et c'est un travail qu'on
a fait qui a duré des mois pour évaluer
tout ce qui pourrait être mis de l'avant
pour renverser la donne faire en sorte
que le fait français soit davantage
présent dans notre bassin des migrants
et vous avez le résultat de ce
travail-là aujourd'hui avec les mesures
de changement réglementaire que l'on
propose mais il fallait faire ce
travail-là on veut engager le fédéral
également dans la mouvance parce que
c'est important lui aussi contrôle une
partie des arrivées donc faut faire en
sorte que le fédéral aussi ils mettent
du sien pour que davantage de personnes
qui émigrent au Québec sont francophones
et je pense particulièrement aux
étudiants étrangers parce que le fédéral
a franchement des mesures qui sont
discriminantes pour les étudiants
africains francophones le taux de refus
est vraiment encore trop élevé et ça ça
pose des enjeux importants pour les
établissements d'enseignement
voulez-vous
africains vous les voulez au Québec là
on veut on les veut pour qu'il vienne
étudier ici puis encore mieux on les
veut pour qu'il reste aussi on les veut
comme immigrants permanent alors la voix
idéale pour l'immigration permanente
pour eux ce serait Le Pecq diplômé on a
besoin que ces gens le viennent mais le
fédéral des refusent en trop grand
nombre merci beaucoup c'est un dossier
extrêmement complexe on a pris quand
même pas mal de temps pour en parler
mais on va en reparler il faut faire la
pédagogie puis il y a des enjeux quand
même qui se posent merci à la prochaine
au revoir